>> Sean: THIS WEEKEND THE FAR
LEFT CAME TOGETHER TO DEMAND
TRUMP'S IMPEACHMENT.
IT WASN'T WELL ATTENDED
ANYWHERE.
WE SENT OUR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE AND INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER, GUY THAT HITS THE
STREET HARD LAWRENCE JONES TO
ONE OF THE RALLIES.
THIS ONE IN NEW YORK CITY TO
ASK WHY SHOULD THE PRESIDENT BE
IMPEACHED?
LET'S WATCH.
>> I'M A HERE BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IN DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED?
>> I DO.
>> WHY?
>> HE IS AN ILLEGAL PRESIDENT.
HE WAS IN CAHOOTS WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
>> WHERE DO YOU BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE IMPEACHED?
>> BECAUSE HE OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE.
COMMITED REALLY IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> IF IT WERE ANY DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT OR EVEN REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPEACHED AND RUN OUT OF OFFICE.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED?
>> NO.
THERE HAS BEEN INVESTIGATION
AFTER INVESTIGATION AND THEY
FOUND NOTHING.
HE HAS BEEN INVESTIGATED MORE
THAN ANY OTHER PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT CRIMES HAS HE COMMITTED?
>> HE WAS -- EVERYTHING WITH
RUSSIA, LIKE HE CONED HIS WAY
INTO OFFICE.
>> THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING UP WITH
AN ILLEGAL, FAKE, ILLEGALLY
ELECTED PRESIDENT FOR OVER TWO
YEARS.
>> WHAT CRIMES DO YOU SUSPECT
THE PRESIDENT HAS COMMITTED?
>> NUMBER ONE, CONSPIRACY WITH
THE RUSSIANS AND HE COVERED IT
UP LIKE YOU CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
A CRIMINAL FOR A LONG TIME.
>> WHY DON'T YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BROUGHT UP THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I WISH I COULD READ PELOSI'S
MIND.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE IS PUTTING
THE COUNTRY IN REAL DANGER?
>> YES, EVERY DAY.
>> HE LOVES OUR COUNTRY.
HE IS A GOOD MAN.
THEY WANT COME  -- COMMUNISM
HERE.
GO TO VENEZUELA.
I'M VERY ANGRY.
>> Sean: THERE WERE SOME VERY
VILE MOMENTS.
TWO MEN APPROACHED LAWRENCE
JONES AND ONE TOLD HIM TO GO
BACK TO FOX NEWS WHERE THERE
IS, QUOTE, MORE COTTON FOR YOU
TO PICK.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ON TAPE BUT
WE DO HAVE THE NEXT COMMENT ON
TAPE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE PEOPLE -- YOU
GO BACK TO KENYA NOW.
>> Sean: HERE NOW IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LAWRENCE JONES.
WE TALKED SATURDAY.
I WAS PRETTY PISSED OFF.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD ME IN A WAY
I DON'T USUALLY GO ON THE AIR,
TRUE OR FALSE.
BUT I'M UPSET THAT THAT
HAPPENED.
TELL US -- TELL EVERYBODY WHAT
I THOUGHT THESE WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE THE ACCEPTING, LOVING,
WONDERFUL, TOLERANT PEOPLE OF
THE LEFT.
APPARENTLY NOT.
>> THIS IS WHO THEY ARE, SEAN.
SO OFTEN THOSE OF US ON THE
RIGHT ARE PAINTED AS THE RACIST
PEOPLE, THE HATEFUL PEOPLE.
YOU DISCUSS THIS ALL THE TIME
ON YOUR PROGRAM.
I WAS JUST ASKING THESE PEOPLE
A SIMPLE QUESTION ABOUT IF THEY
FELT LIKE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE IMPEACHED OR NOT.
THESE GUYS COME UP TO ME AND
SAID GO BACK TO FOX NEWS TO
PICK COTTON.
THEY SAY GO BACK TO KENYA.
THIS IS WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE.
BUT I DOUBT MANY PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA ARE GOING TO CONDEMN
THESE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: THE THING IS, I DON'T
THINK ANY OF THEM WILL, THAT'S
THE SAD THING.
WE'VE BECOME FRIENDS OVER TIME
AND I KNOW IT HAS HAPPENED
BEFORE.
IT HAS HAPPENED TO OTHERS.
SHE WRITES IN HER BOOK JUST
GOOGLE IT.
I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT.
AND IF YOU ARE -- IF YOU'RE
BLACK IN AMERICA AND
CONSERVATIVE FOR WHATEVER
REASON THERE IS -- THERE IS NO
HOLDS BARRED.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS WE HAVE TO
WATCH IT, YOU HAVE TO SAY THE
POILTICALLY CORRECT.
THERE IS NOT EVEN AN OUNCE OF
NICENESS, KINDNESS.
IT IS OPEN SEASON.
WHY IS THAT?
I FRANKLY DON'T GET IT.
>> WELL SEE, THESE GUYS ARE
UPSET AND THEY'RE FEARFUL.
NOTICE, THESE WERE NOT BLACK
PEOPLE SAYING THIS.
THIS WAS THE WHITE, LIBERALS
SAYING THESE TYPE OF THINGS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT WITH OUR
REPORT AND EXPOSING THE POVERTY
AND THE FAILURE OF POLICIES
THAT ALL THESE DEMOCRAT CITIES
HAVE BEEN DOING TO MANY PEOPLE
THAT LOOK LIKE ME, THEY DON'T
WANT THIS TO BE -- THEY BELIEVE
THAT ALL BLACK PEOPLE NEED TO
THINK THE SAME WAY.
THEY WANT US TO STAY ON THE
WELFARE SYSTEM SO WE CAN'T
PROGRESS IN LIFE.
I'M GOING TO EXPOSE IT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
IF THEY THINK I'LL STAND DOWN
BECAUSE THEY YELLED OBSCENE
THINGS TO ME THEY HAVE ANOTHER
THINK COMING.
WE'LL DOUBLE DOWN AND GO TO ALL
THESE LIBERAL CITIES.
ALL THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
WILL HAVE TO ANSWER WHY MY
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO BE IN
POVERTY?
WHY IS THAT?
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
EVERY FOUR YEARS.
NOW IT'S A CONTINUING LOOP
CYCLE.
REPUBLICANS, ISLAMOPHOBIC AND
THROW GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF AND
BY THE WAY, THEY HATE OLD
PEOPLE AND YOUNG KIDS.
NONE OF IT IS TRUE.
BUT I LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT'S
RECORDS.
WE HAVE THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969.
I'M A LITTLE BIT OLDER THAN YOU.
THE METS WON THE WORLD SERIES
IN 1969.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I KNOW, YOU'RE YOUNG AND BETTER
LOOKING AND SMARTER, I KNOW,
WE'RE FRIENDS.
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
BUT LOOK AT AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC AMERICANS, ASIAN
AMERICANS, WOMEN'S IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
RECORDS FOR TRUMP, WHY DO
BIDEN, OBAMA.
WHY DO THEY HAVE THIS HOLD?
WHY?
>> I FEEL LIKE THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE FAILED TO COMMUNICATE OUR
MESSAGE.
WE HAVE ALL THE POLICIES.
ALL THE POLICY POSITIONS THAT
HELPED BLACK AMERICAN KA BUT WE
DON'T GO INTO THOSE COMMUNITY.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD GO INTO
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
>> Sean: THAT'S A GREAT
ANALYSIS.
IT SHOULD NOT HAPPEN.
I CALLED YOU ON SATURDAY AND I
SAID LISTEN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
DO THIS AND YOU SAID TO ME ARE
YOU KIDDING?
I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW I
JUST ADMIRE YOUR STRENGTH, YOUR
COURAGE AND YOUR DESIRE TO GET
OUT AND THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT LOVE YOU AND GO UP TO
LAWRENCE AND HUG HIM AND KISS
HIM ON THE CHEEK.
I'VE SEEN THAT FOOTAGE, TOO,
LAWRENCE.
THIS SHOULD NOT HAPPEN AND I'M
SORRY, MY FRIEND, THAT THAT
HAPPENED.
I'M TRULY SORRY.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU, BROTHER.
>> Sean: LOVE YOU, TOO.
WE'LL TAKE A BREAK AND COME